[Music]
any word
what do you mean word you want me to
call Lewis while his wife is in labor
rather call anybody else about anything
else Harvey Oh Donna he's right it's a
stupid question it's not a stupid
question
y'all just don't know what to do
I mean the only time I've been to a
wedding that got cut short you went to
prison
nothing come on that is some A-Plus
material right there is this thing on
that's not that it's just look at this
nobody's dancing
of course they're not dancing it's weird
it's like they have nothing to celebrate
what do you say we give them something
to celebrate
wait
what are you saying I'm saying I love
you and whether I knew it or not I
wanted to marry you from the second I
met you
oh my God
Donna Roberta Paulson will you marry me
right here right now happy of course
I'll marry you
but right now our families aren't here
and I don't have a dress stop
you look beautiful you can do it again
for our families but if there's one
thing I learned from my mom it's that I
wasted too much time first not forgiving
her
and not admitting how I feel about you
I don't want to waste another second
please will you marry me tonight
what about Rings we don't have any rings
we can find one for me but I have one
for you
that's what was in the envelope
what do you say
I say yes Harvey
yes
thank you
everyone
[Music]
I have an announcement to make
as soon as we can write our vows Donna
and I are getting married
I'd offered to officiate but I'm not
licensed I just don't think we want to
open up that can of worms again
Donna
I kept my feelings inside for so long
because I was afraid but when I finally
got good news that's when I knew you
were my everything
I knew I could always count on you when
the chips were done I just hadn't
realized I couldn't do without you when
they were up
I'm a gambler
I always have been and I always will be
when you're with me
chips are always up
you make me laugh
you made me cry
you make me crazy
but most of all Harvey make me happy
without you I'm empty
I can never go back to the way I was
before
you've changed me and you've changed my
life forever I love you Harvey Specter I
love you Dawn Falls
do you have inspector take down a person
to be a lovely wedded wife right yeah do
you Don a person take half a specter to
be your lovely wedded husband
I do and I Now Pronounce You man and
wife you may kiss the bride
[Music]
[Applause]
as to add to the good news I just heard
from Lewis he's the proud father of a
beautiful baby girl
[Applause]
and we will but right now I want to
dance with my wife
[Music]